aller à toulouse beau monde se doit
si nous ne traitons nous je parle un lot
massif et si un jour elle sera la
famille fait un deuil il compte en
jouant à côté mais nous musiciens nous
la racj un fin ne l'était pas n'était
pas facile donc le seule manière pour
nous fait ni des ccc d'être sur scène
nos missions nous a fait
leur soutien évidemment ça que von doom
une icône et comme les sirops et n'aura
aussi et
un morceau le dernier
[Musique]
oh ça c'est des droits quand mbia hors
tabac en santé aux propositions
normalienne à l'arrivée aujourd hui
thyrion l'amour est laid né l'était
vraiment jolie et je veux exemple à
mardi avant compte sur cette cause que
celle de jason
rendez-vous bac à sable à la safer
c'était des fois la veuve-pin forcément
le ton répéter ou et mais klose a fait à
droite comme défaut de dianous l égard
des bacs à sable noir trouvent
hippodrome l'alpine ou fait certains
viennent nourrir la musique
s'il une théière pas rasé c'est son
maloya sont maniés à santé sont son gaia
est méconnu passionnera encore après
donc bien part atteint au moins c'est ce
moment là où les alentours
wallaby benouahab les gens dit il
[Musique]
le lui